hello folks welcome to rational science
the only site on the internet that does
physics rationally I was looking at a
comment here Einstein was crazy and all
einsteinians are also crazy
well we'll be talking a little bit about
Einstein today so uh we'll get there we
got a busy day today so let's get on
with the show uh here I'm gonna start
with diets which uh we left off kind of
the last two times uh we still don't get
a good answer from people because
they're confusing the issue and this is
what I presented okay
went like this
uh
um
humans evolved
over time right and if we take them back
maybe two million three million years
ago uh we were some kind of or our
ancestor was some kind of monkey you
could say some Proto hominid okay over
time we evolved and we invented Spears
or we discovered that this was a good
tool and I'm saying we use those tools
to hunt animals okay and to defend
ourselves for most of that time around
the time of homo erectus all the way to
uh Modern Man
primarily through that those two million
years we were Hunters more than
gatherers I think uh above 90 percent of
our food was meat
and then lately uh We've switched over
uh to veggies uh which was maybe
anywhere from ten thousand to twenty
thousand years ago when we became more
gatherers and later on Farmers okay so
that's uh in general terms what I'm
suggesting and essentially I'm saying
that we grew up for most of our uh time
as carnivores okay uh does this have
anything to do with health does it have
to do anything with killing poor little
animals and keeping them in Corrals and
in little cages absolutely not that's
politics that's religion that's belief
we don't care about that we just want to
get to the bottom of the issue which is
what is our natural diet it's got
nothing to do with what is healthy it
has nothing to do with what we have
today in other words today we are like I
was explaining the other day we have a
10 to 1 ratio in the amount of veggies
we eat on to plant veggies and fruits
Etc that we eat on the planet compared
to Meats there's almost a 10 to 1 ratio
so 90 of you could say more or less of
what we eat today are vegetables our
plants and not meat
So today we're omnivores but heavily
cited on the uh you know on the Seesaw
we're on the side of veggies that's
essentially where we're at today but
that's not where we were
uh you know a million or two million
years ago that was the point the point
is what is our natural diet we have uh
you know uh these uh canines they're not
very long like in other Predators but we
have them and those are you know Mother
Nature or God or whoever put them there
because of meat okay that's why we have
those here so we are definitely meat
eaters the question is what were we
throughout most of our Evolution and I
would say that at least uh in the last
two million years we were primarily meat
eaters and then at the end we switched
over to veggies so we are all we we have
pretty much been omnivores crew all all
this time and we are still omnivores but
the point is what is our natural diet
and I'm suggesting we're we originated
more towards meat than towards veggies
okay that's simply our Evolutions got
nothing to do with what you like whether
it's healthy whether you like killing
animals none of them has any bearing on
the question okay and so what does one
person ask he says we are apes and apes
eat mostly plants with some meat we
humans should normally eat 60 plant 40
meat again we don't care about the
shoulds okay it's not a question of
shoulds
okay it's a question of what is our
natural diet that's the question we're
trying to answer another fellow says uh
if you can explain science in simple
words a mechanism by which diseases
manifest in humans this has nothing to
do with diseases the question is what is
our natural diet how can we get people
to understand the question so if I'll
continue says why do humans that are
eating omnivore carnivore diets develop
um cancers diabetes etc etc
oh it's got nothing to do with disease
we don't care if it's good for you or
bad for you whether it's eating meat is
good whether eating meat is bad or
veggies or whatever it's got nothing to
do with your opinion we have doctors on
one side and people also uh laymen who
vouch for meats and others who don't
that's all we have those are all
essentially opinions okay and irrelevant
anyways because we don't care what's
good for you we don't care what is
healthy okay that's not the question the
question what is our natural diet what
have we eaten in the last two million
three million years and the answer I
think is primarily meat we were
carnivores we were meat eaters we were
killers of animals we wouldn't be here
if we did not kill animals uh throughout
the Paleolithic okay that's that's the
point okay and again uh what diet is
that unless you can do that then
fighting over what diet is right is
fruitless yeah it's not a question of
what diet is right we don't care about
what's right or wrong those are opinions
and uh you know these people what they
do essentially they're into politics
okay they're into religion they want to
shove down your throat some propaganda
about some type of food and we don't
care about that we care this is a
science site we just trying to get down
to the questions to see if we can answer
some of these basic questions okay
um
so yeah this is the what I propose again
and I'm saying that for the last two
million maybe three millionaires we were
primarily meat eaters uh we switched
lately and I think it's in great measure
because
um it's more efficient to feed people
with grains primarily and other veggies
so you know I don't think you can feed
eight billion people with meat because
you would have to have more cows fish
Birds whatever uh than humans to do that
and you would have to feed them
so it's not practical anymore to be
Hunters you know until or uh you know if
you have Corrals if if you uh keep
livestock Etc uh there's no way you can
feed the world with that anymore okay so
yeah if anything it's an economic and a
question issue or a question of
efficiency
okay uh just for your information here
you have a teeth of T-Rex versus the t
uh teeth of triceratops and I think you
can tell there what each one ate just by
looking at their teeth so teeth are a
good way of showing or or trying to get
to the bottom of the question what is
our natural diet what do our teeth look
like and I was looking at the homo
erectus and I was hoping to find you
know bigger uh canines and that wasn't
the case uh Homo erectus had pretty much
the same mouth in other words the teeth
size was more or less like ours you know
the canines do not stick out like you
know uh
snake or whatever and in fact here here
you can see some of these skeletons here
there's a dog it's got a big canines uh
snake even bigger right
um shark doesn't have really canines but
all these sharp teeth and pointed
inwards so that they can you know take a
chunk and rip it off you
and then you have a cow
no no danger there you can see that
you're not gonna die because a cow eats
you
if anything uh the bull will horn you
but you won't die because of uh a bite
from a cow it could happen I guess you
know but that's not their primary
defense that's that's a predator's uh
attack or whatever
and here you have uh two other animals
the gorilla and um Jeff turns out the
gorilla is primarily or almost
I would say 90 percent a herbivore eat
some termites and other bugs but in
general in general does not eat meat but
they can eat meat okay
um in comparison to like the chimp there
the chimp does eat meat in fact uh
chimps cannibalize other chimps and eat
them you know they they kill them and
eat them and that's not typical among
the uh bigger Apes like the uh gorillas
but uh again the question is were they
originally uh meat eaters did they
switch over to veggies you know this is
something for you to investigate you
know if you want to invest if you want
to get to the bottom of what is the
natural diet of some of these animals
and if it's veggies why does he have you
know these big fangs right so again food
for thought
it's uh stuff that you should be looking
at if you're interested in the subject
okay let's move on to another issue
related issue in that said I presented
this the other day this is a map that I
put in my book Neanderthal book and
um essentially shows that homo erectus
about maybe anywhere between a million
years a million two I'm sorry almost two
million years ago to about 300 000 years
ago around the planet and my argument is
that they came out of Africa it's in Out
of Africa
um Theory or assumption and they ended
up in Mary old England about at least
800 000 years ago we have Footprints and
some uh Flint tools here Etc okay so uh
uh one uh so the question is you know
did they come out of Africa or uh was it
like a multi-regional issue which is
known as the Mochi Regional Theory where
humans developed or Homo erectus at
least at that level originated in
different parts of the world
simultaneously or in parallel okay and
which is true the humans uh or our
ancestors right originate in Africa or
in several places at once
and uh one fellow says the following
he says uh a species will have the
highest diversity in the region which it
originates Africa had the highest
genetic diversity of all human
populations Americans have the lowest
this means that we originated in Africa
okay so this is this what this fellow
found out there or this is what he
subscribes to and I do have a problem
with this not because uh humans did not
originate in Africa but the reason given
and it's got to do with this another
comment by another fellow which is uh
the Out of Africa uh the molecular clock
issue he says it seems that the whole
Out of Africa stems out of the molecular
clock method of dating
first of all I'll say absolutely not
that's not where it originates that is
another theory okay called the molecular
clock to which I personally do not
subscribe okay but it assumes that
mutation rate is constant across species
well it has already been shown many
times that it is not the case the
multi-regional hypothesis instead is
based on the fossil record and that's
the one I subscribe to okay I say that
it has to do with fossil record
primarily and no that's not what the
multi-regional
hypothesis leads to the multi the fossil
record leads to the Out of Africa and I
want to make a point of that leads to
the Out of Africa hypothesis not to the
multi-regional okay and I'll provide a
little bit of an example today okay but
there's a third alternative okay
stemming from this understanding of the
uh feasibility of viability of the
molecular clock where ancient humans
would have come out of Asia
discovered by a Chinese scientist now
that's a
a little bit nationalistic right nobody
notably the idea that genetic diversity
is a sign of recent evolution in low
selectivity and or heavy in pathogens
well low genetic diversity a sign of
evolution under harsh selective
pressures vaporizing favoring right more
specific genes okay so what's the issue
the issue is that uh the Chinese and I
wrote about this in my book as well the
Neanderthal book uh Chinese want to
claim that humans originated in China
okay there's a lot of nationalism behind
that theory okay Communist party is also
pushing for that theory imagine if they
could prove to the world that humans
originated in China right and as of
today and again because of the fines the
sights that we have out there there is
no evidence for that theory okay or for
that assumption that you're just going
to take it as an assumption this is what
I put in my book okay for you to see and
it's uh these are the Chinese finds as
of uh the date that I wrote the book
that I think it was 2015 16 something
like that
um and you can see they're the sites in
China and at the erectus level okay
which goes from anywhere from 1.9 to uh
maybe 800 000 years ago that's primarily
the range for erectus after that we have
a Heidelberg type creature uh and again
these lines are very abstract uh very
opinionated it's just to give a sense of
that there's been a change from one type
of human or humanoid or plummeted from
one type to another okay and the oldest
ones that you'll find in China and uh
you got to qualify this quite a bit okay
but other ones there neither one and she
who do okay those are the oldest ones
that we found in China
um the dates have shifted quite a bit
okay that's one issue uh different
opinions then the question whether any
of the stone tools found especially the
oldest ones are natural or whether
they're man-made that was another issue
and we haven't really found many bones
uh in fact I think none at all it's just
tools that they found and again the
tools and the stones uh According to
some were just natural stones and have
nothing at all to do with man-made
stones uh the closest you can probably
get is maybe around a million years ago
and that's the uh gang One Wing uh the
uh Legend uh is around 800 000 years ago
which is about to switch over from
erectus to Heidelberg that's about the
age of the really the documented uh
verified right that we have a something
here you know a skeleton a hit now China
has not
um excavated as much as Africa so you
know you have to take that into
consideration the question is as of
today there is no evidence that uh
erectus was in China
any time before 800 000 years ago there
are some uh
very debatable uh evidence that's out
there there's still Excavating we have
to wait for more results but if you
compare that against Africa which is 1.9
million years ago and even before that
you got 2.3 million years ago you have
Homo habilis
right which is the first uh creature
that is making tools standing up and
making tools
uh I doubt very much you're going to
find any habilis anywhere in China but
again maybe it's too early to make that
call my suggestion is that humans did
originate in Africa and began began to
roam the planet from there some went as
far as China and Indonesia uh
I've got several couple at least not
several but a couple of um
uh sites that were excavated where they
found you know a skull and you'll find a
lot more in Africa and if they also this
erectus also went West and reached the
British Isles which I talked about the
other day about 800 000 years ago you
find Footprints and
um some stone tools and Bones of uh
uh what is it uh mammoths in England and
so you know you have to think that you
know erectus did not originate in
England I think he originated in Africa
and went to England
and I think the same thing happened to
China
okay so that's my five cents worth on
that
okay uh let's look at some other issues
related to Extinction here we have a
fellow who says we are way too many
anyway we need a massive reduction for
Earth's sake and for Humanity itself
women aren't having kids could have
fooled me uneducated people have the
more kids
and I think uh yeah this was not
um very familiar with the issue uh and I
mentioned that the other day here's the
picture that's 19th century it was the
rich people who had kids
okay let me repeat that in the 19th
century beginning in the 20th century it
was the rich people who had lots of kids
okay and so this notion that people have
today that it's the poor people who have
children Africa wasn't having children
in the 19th century Africa started the
continent right primarily uh sub-Saharan
Africa started having children in the
20th century in the 19th century it was
the developing nations Europe United
States primarily Japan those were the
countries or the regions where
population was growing it was growing
exponentially uh why because of
manufacturing it was exploding people
were getting rich there was a lot of
work
and in that environment people
procreated people
okay uh so this is uh Miss uh conception
that this fellow has
another fellows has something similar he
said I live in the Philippines and the
Queen City of the South Cebu uh there
doesn't seem to be any shortage of
children including very poor kids with
nobody to support them who live on the
streets begging it doesn't appear to me
that cities deter Filipinos from having
children
and again this is what happens when you
just judge by your city I mean I've been
in Buenos Aires you see same thing you
see children begging you in the streets
you see uh uh you know in many of these
countries you'll see that and you're
gonna you're not going to judge
uh how population grows from what you
see in the city
you know uh you get the wrong version of
what's really going on okay so let me
give you an example it's known as
statistics okay uh statistics are a
little better for this kind of problem
you don't just go out there and look at
the city and say oh there's a lot of
kids there looks like you know it's the
poor people who are having people uh who
are having children right no the way you
do it is this way okay you look at the
trends and here you have China's birth
rate it's been falling since 1979 uh
when they had the one child uh per
family policy then they switched over to
two child policy two child per family
policy and that didn't change anything
it just keeps going down down now China
is giving money to people that have
children and it's still going down
people are not having children
and you say what's going on and
obviously no one has any idea out there
you want to know what's going on you got
to come only to the site it's the only
side of the world that tells you why
we're not having children okay you won't
find it with any of the experts out
there that because there are no experts
this is the reason we're not having
children especially Chinese okay
urbanization everybody's moving to the
cities and because you moved to the
cities you stop having children uh
that's the main or the underlying reason
that affects both economics and culture
okay uh crowdedness
there's several things related to that
but the driving force is urbanization
people are going from the country to the
city when you get to the city you can't
have 10 children like you used to have
in the country that's the main reason
that's the underlying reason why the
entire planet is now uh growing
asymptotically in other words the growth
rate population growth rate is not
exponential anymore in any country even
in Nigeria South uh sub-Saharan Africa
everybody's got the wrong idea they say
oh these black people are having
children no no no believe me you have
black people in the United States
they're not having children if they live
in cities
okay if they live in cities they're not
going to have children they're going to
have one or two maybe and that's it and
not even that much not even they're not
even getting married a lot of them so
it's gotten nothing to do with race it's
got nothing to do with how much money
you have in your pocket okay it's got to
do with urbanization you move to the
city no more jobs or you have uh meager
jobs that barely take you to the end of
the month and people realize immediately
they cannot have 10 children especially
in an apartment that's the issue okay so
urbanization is what drives population
down okay and it's inevitable all
countries every single country on the
planet you have people there's this
transition going on where people are
moving from the country to the cities
every single country there's no
exception on the planet okay you can
look it up and find an exception for me
throw it in my face okay
but that's what's happening okay
transition country to the city known as
urbanization
okay uh another issue that came up uh
was uh China
and one fellow says the Western Empire
is crashing and burning I guess he hates
the Western Empire America became the
financial capital of the world after a
second world war okay China will secure
that title after the third
well I don't know about this guy's
crystal ball uh
disagree with him
um
I think the third world war is very
likely to come unless uh the the global
economy collapses before then but I
think part of that collapse will be a
World War so I think they're going to
come kind of simultaneously
after World War III or after the
collapse of the global economy whichever
comes first
or if they come simultaneously there
will not be a world after that okay or
like I think it was Einstein who says I
don't know how the third world war will
be fought but the fourth one will be
fought with sticks and stones
there will be nothing left after that
okay we'll we'll be throwing stones at
each other whoever's left okay so no
after a third world war it's over for
all of us okay we will not restart the
raised partly because our genetic
diversity is gone so even if there's a
pocket of humans that survives they will
not reproduce the uh the population of
earth like Adam and Eve that's gone so
those people who think that somehow
we're going to restart the race again
and grow and for another million years
well they don't have the slightest clue
okay okay so let's see here we have
another five and I think he said uh 10
isn't a service economy
laugh out loud yeah China is a service
economy okay he uh he he
he's laughing at his own ignorance
because I showed that the other day but
let me show it one more time China is
now a service economy okay this is uh
labor and you can see what's happening
just with labor labor has been growing
since at least 2011 on this chart you
can see how agriculture industry is
dying down what's growing your services
so Services is now at 48 according to
this and there's only 29 percent of
um labor in Blue Collar jobs
manufacturing agriculture is another 22
percent okay that's according to this
chart but let's look at GDP okay that's
important too we're probably more
important okay this is 2013 primary
industry agriculture ten percent uh
manufacturing blue collar workers uh 44
tertiary the service in sector 46 for
the first time around 2014 through 2013
services overpassed or surpassed
Manufacturing
it used to be more uh manufacturing now
uh GDP is mainly coming from the service
sector that means it has become a more
service oriented economy but that was in
2013 here's 2017. you can see again
uh how it went from Manufacturing in
1978 47.7 percent there at the bottom
left and now you can see that tertiary
which was 24 went up to 51 percent while
a manufacturing dropped to 40 percent so
51 more than 58 of the Chinese economy
is now coming out of services and not
out of Industry okay
you can see what's happening and that
Trends continuing here you see uh how
that second how that service economy in
China is divided okay uh transport and
storage and post hotel and Catering real
estate wholesale and Retail financial
intermediation and then you have the
others so that's how it's divided that's
what's growing specifically what is
growing is probably that other which is
um internet services what's growing in
the pl on the planet is internet and
internet is what I call unemployment
it's um it's a Leisure and entertainment
um
economy
it's a rich man's economy okay you have
servants doing everything for you it's
like you're the Pharaoh and you pay for
services uh you want a pizza you don't
even have to walk to the pizza shop you
just phone them in and they bring you
the pizza to your house you buy
everything on the internet so it's like
all these people you don't even know
where it's where it comes from all you
know is that you need a coat and you go
out there and buy it on the internet and
they send it to you so you don't know
who made it where it came from you don't
care you just look at you know do your
shopping on the internet even the malls
are dying nobody's going out there
anymore so um yeah internet is uh
unemployment it's a rich man's economy
it's a leisure in entertainment uh
economy and we cannot survive on Leisure
and entertainment and that is what is
growing in every country in the world
especially the advanced Nations so there
is no future no future whatsoever uh
once they fill all the entertainment and
Leisure quota uh anyone who comes next
well he'll have a hard time breaking
into that Monopoly into that uh Guild
right
um yeah if he who hits first hits twice
that's the way it works and these people
are hitting twice whoever gets those
Services first those are the companies
that will grow anyone who comes later
it'll just be a consumer not a producer
okay someone asked me about chat GPT not
exactly about that but he asked the
question to the chat GPT to see what
kind of answer he got and so he had a
little debate a little discussion with
with a robot okay and it was about the
word exist
okay and so he says the definition of
exist as an object with location and
physical presence is an objective
definition that's what the bot told him
okay so the bot liked it at least they
like my definition okay yes the bot at
least analyze it to some point but then
the bot screwed itself when it went
forward with more and shows you why you
got to be careful with all these chat
Bots uh chat gpts and Bots uh it's worth
noting however that the concept of
existence can still be influenced by
subjective factors such as human
perception interpretation and language
absolutely not
now because when you make it subjective
you no longer have an objective
definition and that definition you know
physical presence goes down the drain
okay you cannot uh Define it in such a
way that you Encompass uh subjectivity
as well okay and that's where the
problem is either you you and again
we're doing it for physics where we're
going to be using it consistently
scientifically rationally and not uh
what we have today in the dictionaries
where you know anything goes over there
especially synonyms and then it gives
you an example says different cultures
and languages may have different
definitions or understandings of what it
means for something to exist based on
their unique philosophical or scientific
traditions we clean our nose hose with
all that we don't care what any language
on the planet says and a lot of them
just copy from other languages we don't
care they have to rationalize the usage
of the word exist so it's not a question
of saying well you know this guy has a
different opinion on the word exist if
he does no problem defend your
definition if you cannot defend it uh
it's easy to tear apart then we throw it
in the trash can just that simple so the
bud screwed it up it should have stopped
at the first uh line there and not
continue okay so what is uh this chat
GPT box uh this R2D2 that has become
famous lately okay and here's a little
definition or explanation it says 10 gbt
is a versatile chat bot that mimics a
human cons conversational list chat
boxer Chatterbox is a software
application used to conduct an online
chat conversation via text or text to
speech in lieu of providing direct
content with what with a live Human
agent regretting rid of humans from the
workforce we're replacing them with Bots
chat Bots and a lot of companies have
them unfortunately our computer programs
designed to convincingly simulate the
way a human would have would behave as a
conversational partner they are capable
of maintaining a common conversation
with a user in natural language etc etc
okay and it says Ted TPT can write and
debug computer programs compose music
teleplays fairy tales and student essays
answer test questions write poetry and
song lyrics emulate a Linux system
simulate an entire chat room play games
like Tic-tac-toe and simulate an ATM
and then at the end this is all out of
um Wikipedia in 2012 none of them could
pass the standard Turing test
uh-huh so it could pass the Turing test
well what in the world is a Turing test
let's find out just so we
zero in on the spot okay here it is
during test is a test of a machine's
ability to exhibit intelligent Behavior
equivalent to or this indistinguishable
from that of a human a human evaluated
would judge natural language
conversations between a human and a
machine designed to generate human-like
responses the evaluator would be aware
that one of the two partners in
conversation was a machine if the
evaluator could not reliably tell the
machine from the human the machine would
be said to have passed the test
okay so you have these this evaluator
this interrogator he's isolated from the
two uh
uh
entities that will be answering
questions and he knows one of them is a
robot but if he can't tell the
difference between them uh then that
means uh that the bot passed a Turing
test okay so that's the that's the
criteria okay for determining you know
whether a bot uh is intelligent or not
but we have a
an article that came out and I'll just
synthesize it here it says Google's AI
passed a famous test and showed how the
test is broken the Turing test has long
been a benchmark for machine
intelligence but what it really measures
is deception does it measure
intelligence it measures deception and
goes in there and says look uh you know
these uh tests aren't really getting at
intelligent what it's getting at is the
capacity of a given software program to
pass as human at least under certain
conditions it's an advance towards
fooling people that you have
intelligence we don't need to worry
about Lambda turning into Skynet Etc you
know machine mind from the Terminator
right the AI sector has largely moved on
with using deterring tests as an
explicit Benchmark the designers of
large language models now aim for high
scores on tests the Turing test most
troubling Legacy is an ethical one the
test is fundamentally about deception
the Turing test should serve as an
ethical red flag any system capable of
passing it carries the danger of
deceiving people
in other words the the point of the
Turning test was uh allegedly to put
like a benchmark like a uh if you pass
this test well uh you show that you have
lots of intelligence and what it
actually shows is that the bot is able
to fool people because it even makes
sounds like coughing and uh
um and so on and whoever listens to that
says well is that a bot or is that a
human because all that's programmed in
there okay and so the question is does
that show Intelligence or does that show
deception and the argument there was it
doesn't show Intelligence will a bot of
any kind in the future ever have the
ability uh to think like a human
um it's difficult to believe that that
it will reach that level okay they can
mimic a lot of things and obviously
they're getting more sophisticated as
time goes by the question is will they
ever become human
and my answer to that is there's not
enough time to reach that Milestone uh
Humanity will disappear way before that
time
okay let's move on to some of the
subject matters of today
let me clean up here a little bit uh you
got a lot of stuff here
a second
okay uh one issue that popped uh from
last time was I talked about existence
okay and uh so there were some people
who uh gave it their best shot on what
they believe the word exist or existence
means okay and the fellow says there I
take existence to be but a part of all
things that have been
well uh being is a synonym of exist so
you can't use the word beam if you're
going to be defining the word exist to
exist is to have spatial temporal
properties
okay whatever that means okay however I
would not want to reduce the whole of
ontagi to existence otherwise we'll have
severe problems dealing with semantics
for there is no semantics without
ontology well antology philosophical
study of being existence as well as
related Concepts such as existence
becoming in reality all of which are
synonyms of existence so we don't know
what antagi is other than existence and
we don't know what existence is and
semantics is meaning in language okay oh
I'm not sure what this fell said unless
he says a little more we don't
understand what's going on in through
his head
and here's an iPhone he says an object
exists if it interacts with another
object
so the question is
um uh here we have um
an asteroid just flying through space
until it hits the moon it's not it
doesn't exist it has to interact with
the moon for it to become not only an
object but for it to exist
so no interaction does not define
existence exist is a static concept
interaction is a dynamic concept
interact is a verb okay a property
exists if sentience can observe an
object with that property so
um uh in order for a property to exist
he's saying that a property exists right
and again he hasn't defined uh exists
very well because he says an object
exists but now he says a property exists
now you're saying that a concept an
abstract concept exists and he says in
order for it to exist it has to have an
observer
observe it that means that uh you know
um there were no properties
uh in the universe behold before humans
came around
okay that's what he's saying essentially
all those properties like you know Mars
was red maybe and uh the moon was round
and uh the sun was hot all those
properties only began to exist when
humans became it came into existence
uh that's very hard to believe you know
that those properties weren't there
before humans and a concept exists if an
object with sentience can Define it
[Laughter]
so uh again we don't know what exists
means so we can't know what uh how he
means that a concept exists in what way
does it exist what does exist mean
so again unless he defines the word
exists four Concepts
uh in an objective Manner and he can't
do that if he puts observers into the
picture uh then he doesn't have a
definition he can't defend his
definition
and here we have still another guy says
exists having objective reality
well reality is what a synonym of
existence that's the first problem but
he says such as energy
energy is a concept there's no physical
object called Energy
but you are welcome to draw it or show
us a picture of it point to a picture
anywhere on the internet so we know what
energy looks like okay and until that
happens uh we're gonna say that energy
is an object if it's not an object
according to a definition physical
presence it cannot said to be to exist
okay so yeah you can't use the word
reality that's a synonym that already
destroys your definition
okay so let's uh compare this well also
had some other definitions and he says
this the following says object a
collection of matter location position
and again now oh he's using a synonym
because matter is uh you know just a
bunch of objects that's what matter is
location position position you look it
up it's location so space a
three-dimensional huh what
space is three-dimensional I thought
space had no Dimensions whatsoever
space is nothing I thought nothing had
no dimensions
so unless you can draw space and show us
that it has three dimensions uh
uh through a drawing or some kind of
mock-up of some kind you know you have
to draw it or bring it to the conference
room and show us this is space and then
we'll see the shape of it and say yeah
you're right that's three dimensional
but until you can do that you don't have
three-dimensional all you have is
nothing nothing is Zero Dimensional okay
uh distance a magnitude or size of
displacement well he's confusing
distance with displacement displacement
is the number of tiles distance is the
separation between two objects
okay and so these are two different
concepts the one in physics is the one
distance displacement is not used in
physics that's totally 100 percent a uh
mathematical concept you know number of
tiles how many meters how many inches
that that kind of stuff does not concern
physics at all we don't have no need for
that because physics is about explaining
you don't explain anything by saying how
many feet or how many inches are from
here to there
motion change translation rotation well
change is to make different from what it
was before you did you changed it we
left it alone okay so yeah change in
motion are synonyms that's not a
definition and time a measure of the
interval you look up interval and
intervening period of time
so yeah this uh thinks that all they do
is just copy what they see in the
dictionary and Wikipedia or on the
Internet and that's why they arrive at
these uh definitions but these
definitions are just copied uh it it is
and even attempted to defend it to
reason them out to see if they make
sense he just said well that's how we
did it always and by tradition and
because everybody voted you know
democracy uh uh and Authority you know
the fact that we have the people in uh
at the universities who tell us to use
these definitions so he's going with
democracy Authority and um
and uh what is it and uh the fact that
in democracy
uh whatever uh the point is you can't
use those uh tradition with the other
one uh you can't use any of those as
arguments you have to defend the
definition okay and unless you can
defend the definition you're
definition is no good not simple okay so
here let's compare what this file said
to ours the first problem with what this
fellow said is that he's got him in the
wrong order he starts with exist then
works with object then location then
space then distance and eventually ends
up with motion that's not the way it's
done in science okay especially in
physics the way it works is you have to
have a certain order to these words you
have to Define what an object something
is first
okay and then from there you have to
work your way to distance location exist
motion and concept okay that's the way
it works in science
now this file says you know he says
having objective reality such as energy
reality is exists so it's a he's using a
synonym
object and identifiable collection of
matter you look up matter it's many
objects that's what matter is so again
that definition is circular okay
location positioning conceptual axis
position is a place where something is
located so location and position are
synonyms and just in case place is also
is sent into a position so all these are
synonyms you can't use synonyms to
Define
a synonym is a circular definition
space is a three-dimensional but
Continuum what's it Continuum a
continuous extent
a set of elements such as that between
any two of them there is a third element
what's an extent the space to which a
thing extends
something extended as a space so yeah
all he's done is run around in circles
why because he doesn't look up these
words he doesn't understand that you
can't use synonyms and you can't run
around in circles you got to look up
each one of those words and find out
what it means and if it goes back to if
Continuum goes back to space and you get
a circular argument okay so you can't
use a word that already
um contains the word you're trying to
Define
this tends the magnitude of size of
displacement again displacement is not
distance and motion change etc etc and
changes motion now the way we Define
these things in Sciences seen on the
right something that which has shape
nothing that which doesn't have shape
that's what the synonym is space okay so
space is that which doesn't have shape
and object is that which does this does
separation between two objects location
is the set of distances to all other
objects exist physical presence meaning
the uh an object that has location
something with location motion two or
more locations of an object right and
concept a word that invokes or embodies
two objects or two words treated as
objects
okay
so um
unless you can challenge those
definitions not not through Authority
not through democracy not through
tradition uh but through reasoning then
you don't have a case right
hey and uh so uh another fellow says
finally he says what is matter
that's maybe number three after
existence and thinness now as I just
said uh you have to go in that order you
have to go first with object you can do
space as well because it's an antonym of
object then you go through distance
location
and then finally to exist existence and
motion
that's that's the direction in which you
must do it in physics that that
direction is mandatory you cannot Escape
it you cannot Define location before you
define an object you cannot Define
existence or motion before you define
object or distance or location Okay so
the order is very important and matter
is just the objects that exist many
objects that exist we refer to matter as
all the atoms or objects depending on
you you can choose your your system
right uh that exist that have physical
presence that are objects that have
location so matter is just many objects
that have location period we're done
okay let's get to the subject matter
today which is time okay and here we're
gonna have a little bit of trouble uh
one fella uh does a terrible job of
trying to figure out what time is and
we'll see what he has to say but here it
is these are the questions I want you to
keep in mind what is time okay that's
one issue what is time okay is it a what
does time exist well if we go with the
physical presence definition you have to
have an object in time it's not an
object so we're done time cannot exist
according to that definition of
existence right does time flow well I
mean for that we need to Define what
time is the does time flow like a river
uh roll like a ball I mean you let me
know and it's time infinite a question
that uh concerned a lot of people
especially Aristotle okay he was
concerned about that whether it was
infinite or finite okay so he's going to
address that okay so let's uh get on uh
with uh the fella who really
um almost almost analyzed it to
exhaustion and that was Aristotle and
again maybe it wasn't him alone he had a
school he had students they all wrote
and today we give all that credit to
Aristotle the question is whether that
was all his writing or whether that was
done by several students or it was a
concerted effort from Aristotle and his
students okay but that's a secondary
issue let's find out what Aristotle or
his generation or his school had to say
about time and here's the first one says
one part of it has been and is not while
the other is going to be and is not yet
he's talking about past and future yet
time both infinite time and any time you
like to take is made up of these one
would naturally suppose that what is
made up of things which do not exist
could have no share in reality yeah
because existence in reality in reality
is existence
further if a divisible thing is to exist
it is necessary that when it exists all
or some of its parts must exist but of
time some parts have been While others
have to be and no part of it is though
it is divisible in other words he's
saying you know the the past doesn't
exist the future has never happened so
neither one of those exists what's left
well what's left is the now the present
for what is now is not a part A Part is
a measure of the whole which must be
made up of parts
okay time on the other hand is not held
to be made up of Nows
okay so let's see if we understand what
he's saying how he's presenting the
problem he's saying the past doesn't
exist the future does has not happened
so it doesn't exist and the present is
the now but time is not made up of Nows
okay
and part partly because the now has to
be made up of Parts itself
okay so this is how he starts his uh his
discussion this gold good old area about
uh 350 years before Christ okay
and he continues in his reasoning all
this is from physics it's book four
right time is most usually supposed to
be motion and a kind of change uh-huh
but he says the change or movement of
each thing is only in the thing which
changes but time is present equally
everywhere and with all things so it's
not part of the thing itself he's saying
and then he says change is always faster
or slower whereas time is not for fast
and slow are defined by time fast is
what moves much moves much in a short
time slow what moves little in a long
time but time is not defined by Time by
being either a certain amount or a
certain kind of it clearly then it is
not movement
okay you see what he's saying here he's
saying um you know time can go faster
I'm sorry motion can go faster or slower
but time always ticks at the same rate
so he says time is some is related
somehow to motion but time is not motion
there's a difference
okay that's his reasoning and in a way
he's right so he's doing okay to a
certain degree okay then he finally ends
the following says neither does time
exist without change for when the state
of our minds does not change at all we
do not realize that time has elapsed
okay
and so uh yeah in other words if you're
thinking right if you're
um
thinking about the same thing constantly
time is still flowing he's saying even
though you can say that your thought has
not changed uh it's always in the same
subject maybe you're the same image
maybe you're thinking of a chair and but
time is Flowing every second that you're
thinking of that
so that's his first point he says
evidently time is not independent of
movement and change time is neither
movement nor independent of movement
time is either movement or something
that belongs to movement since it is not
movement it must be the other in other
words he says time is what belongs to
movement some property of movement time
is just this number of motion in respect
to before and after time is not movement
but only movement in so far as it admits
of enumeration
okay
uh the question is what is uh he
referring to here you know I mean uh it
makes you kind of wonder whether he's uh
he's got a handle on this issue okay
uh give me a second here
because I want to show you something
here this is what he had in mind okay
he's uh saying even if you're thinking
the same thing all the time in this case
he's thinking about a girl apparently
and you show the same distance to
everything in the room okay time is
still flowing it's still ticking
so what Arie was really doing is uh
identifying time with a number line he's
saying time is a number line because
he's talking about enumeration of
movement he's giving a number to
movement even though there is no
movement in in a sense that he has the
same distance everything in the room he
used the analogy of a boat you know
being uh you you inside the boat have
the same distance everything inside the
boat but you're moving perhaps with
respect to the um to the uh Coast okay
the ship could be moving with respect to
the coast and so he's saying uh you have
the same distance everything in the room
but time is still flowing
okay so he identified it really with a
number line that was his his uh notion
and here he says is a proof of this is
we discriminate the more or the less by
number but more or less movement by time
time then is a kind of number
okay
time is not motion but the number or
measure of motion okay
uh yeah but he just didn't understand
what he was saying
because if you're going to do a measure
of motion
you are moving as well
so we have two motions we have the
motion of the thing you're measuring
plus your act of measuring which is
another motion we're comparing two
motions okay keep that in mind
that's what he didn't figure out
okay uh
next guy to really tackle the subject of
time was
um
St Augustine and I like it because in
his confessions you know I mean he was
from the days of clepsidras
uh you know the drop of water the
Chinese torture you know until you know
you fill the bucket then you know that's
15 minutes or one hour or whatever how
however big your eclipse of dry is right
and Saint Augustine you said the same
but the following said for what is time
who can readily and briefly explain this
it was beyond his uh capability of
understanding what time is who can even
in thought comprehend it
uh so as to utter a word about it
well a Fella's name is Bill gai I can do
that uh I have no problem answering that
question but he said famously right he
says if no one asked me I know he knows
what time is if I wish to explain it to
one that asketh I know not
so he wasn't able to define the word for
someone else he just has an intuitive no
an intuitive notion of what time is he
says well you know we all know what time
is which is what Newton later would say
it's like you know we know what time is
so there's no need to explain or Define
it but if you ask him to Define if you
ask him to explain it that's where he
dies he says well you know I I can't
explain I can't define it great uh but
because of that he was able to write his
confessions and he had this notion of of
what time was and that is in relation to
God he apparently he was a man of the
cloth okay and so he had this notion
about time related to God he says it is
consciousness which differentiates
between what has happened is happening
and will happen and he says it this way
he says it is in you my mind that I
measure periods of time so he's saying
it's something inside my head the
Consciousness that's that's where time
comes in
okay and so that's a little bit tricky
because now he's going to relate that to
God and he says what did God do before
he created the universe
and I'm sure a lot of people had asked
him that he had to find an answer to
them these this is how he uh
reason this this answer okay he says God
is not Material
not a thing God is spirit so says the
Bible right the spirit of God when uh
over the waters right
God doesn't move
that's a new one God doesn't move
I don't know how God cannot move but if
he's Spirit which is a concept uh then
we can understand that and say yeah if
God is a spirit if God is some kind of
abstraction then we cannot imagine a
concept moving
so in that sense he was right okay keep
that in mind God is eternal
okay it's always there present tense in
other words he's always into present
that's why he's eternal
okay and he doesn't move
because he's a concept he's a spirit
okay so far is it good
um God is outside the universe so the
spirit is outside the universe he was
thinking of what became known eventually
as the block Universe the universe is
there
and not only the universe be it the
entire history of the universe is there
from beginning to end from big bang to
Big Crunch okay the whole works it's all
there in front of God God doesn't move
God is a spirit
okay God is not an object not a thing
yeah
but the universe he created how they
created I guess without movement I don't
know but God is miraculous I guess he
creates this universe okay it's in front
of him that's a black universe and
obviously God then uh knows what's going
to happen in the future in the past
that's how you know he can relate to all
that because he sees it all there in
front of him but uh time is part of the
universe not of God not it's not outside
the universe
okay so space time all in the block
Universe you know all these people
Einstein and his generation they didn't
discover anything and that was already
had come from Saint Augustine the black
Universe was what he was talking about
he's saying that time is part of the
universe and God is outside the universe
which is more or less where relativity
ended up today okay so yeah he had the
notion of the block universe
okay we can get really quick the nice
guy who just babbled a little bit about
time that was Newton and he said I do
not Define time etc etc
being well known to all
so if you know what time is why take the
trouble to Define it right and then he
talked about absolute true and
mathematical time of itself and from its
own nature flows
flying like a river equally without
relation to anything external and by
another name is called duration relative
apparent and common time is some
sensible and external whether it's
accurate or unequable measure of
duration by the means of motion
okay so again he's measuring duration
he's measuring time he's measuring an
object that's moving and what is
measuring if not another motion we're
comparing two motions when we measure an
object that moves we're comparing two
motions keep that in mind which is
commonly used instead of true time such
as our day month and year okay so uh he
was referring uh to this absolute time
that's out there in the universe okay
you thought there was some kind of time
out there and
um and things moved with respect to that
time I guess
so I'm not sure exactly what he had in
mind and that's more or less why he said
he wasn't going to Define time because
it was too difficult or you would not
understand and more like Saint Augustine
said
um I cannot explain it or Define it for
you but we all know what it is and
Newton ended up with the same notion
okay uh then we can jump again to the
end of the 19th century beginning in the
20th century and we have these fellows
uh we have a heavy side and Fitzgerald
and Lawrence and they came up with this
notion that time is relative not
absolute as Newton thought
um it depends on the motion of observers
and if you measure at one point and then
measure at another Point well you get a
different uh sense of time okay and that
depends on who's
taking notes okay so uh they have this
notion of relative time and they had to
come up with this nonsense because they
couldn't accept the results of the um
Michelson Morty experiment
where they said that there is no ether
they checked light going in One
Direction Another Direction they
expected for there to be a difference
there was no difference no matter how
they tested it and so what these people
came up with they said well when uh the
when light travels in the same direction
as the Earth it's getting squashed
and what's squashing it is time in other
words the time is shortened and they
started playing around with this
relative time depends on you know if
you're going perpendicular or parallel
to the motion of the earth so they had
to create this notion of squash time
okay time dilation okay
and um so here we have a few years later
we have minkowski and he gave a
presentation in which he merged
unbelievably he merged time with space
like you know uh oil with water that's
more or less how they merge they blend
you're talking about two different
things altogether but they merged them
and they said the concepts of time and
space which I would like to develop
before you today have grown on it have
grown up have grown unexperimental
physical grounds hearing lies their
strength their tendency is radical okay
henceforth Space by itself and Time by
itself shall completely reduce to a mere
Shadow and only some sort of Union of
the two shall preserve Independence
he moved space with time and screwed up
all the mathematicians who came
afterwards okay who believe in this
nonsense okay so yeah they merged space
and time y because
um they just wanted to do math they had
no idea about physics this has nothing
to do with physics with the real world
out there it says it has solely to do
with math well after uh minkowski came
up with that Einstein came in a few
years later and he started bending time
he started warping time space time sorry
and of course when you bend space time
you're bending time itself and so time
is what's being bent being warped and
that makes no sense whatsoever
because what they did was they
replaced time with a fishnet like you
know they reified the concept and the
concept became a fishnet and then they
started putting weights on The Fishnet
and they said look it it warps and if it
warps then anything that is caught in
that region is going to roll around
forever you know the Earth around the
Sun okay for example and uh yeah that's
the notion that uh relativity has today
that uh the physical interpretation for
their equations so the equation we don't
care about those that has to do with
mathematics what we care about is the
physical interpretation and these people
are saying that you sink The Fishnet
that represents time you have reified
time now okay you represent it with a
fishnet why not with a tree why not with
a rock no it had to be a fish in it so
that you could warp it and explain that
you know the Earth rolls around the sun
because the fishnet is Warped it's
circular it's like the roulette
mechanism essentially
okay uh so what do we have today well we
have people like Brian green and he um
took Newton and he says um Newton had
this notion of absolute time which was
like a flowing river
out there and Einstein froze the river
created his
uh block Universe okay and here it is
there you uh see good old uh Brian Green
says Newton's floating River you know
and what I'd say and it would freeze it
okay and then now you can walk towards
the future because the future is already
there we have the block universe
okay and here you can see what he does
next he goes in there and he slices up
uh this base time
um Universe this uh
thing that they call space time this uh
it's like a tunnel or you could say he's
going to represent it essentially with a
loaf of bread but you can see the slices
there each one of those lines that cuts
across space time that's time
okay but see time is an interval you
need two frames of the movie to
conceptualize time and here he's
cheating because he puts a single line
through there like if it was a cross
section of time time is really flowing
from where he's at all the way to the
right time is the whole thing okay so
that's the axis on the bottom you could
say but uh time there's no such thing as
a single point in time because time
requires at least two frames of the
movie so you cannot have time in a
single frame okay but that's how they
cheat that's without knowing because I
think they don't even understand what
they're doing there so they draw these
lines across space-time and it gets even
worse because what green does next he
takes he represents this whole thing as
a loaf of bread and you can see what he
does he's going to slice across the loaf
of bread and again he calls that a slice
of time
and there's no such thing as a slice of
time okay uh what he has is location not
time time requires motion time requires
as we all already all these predecessors
said you know you require motion you
have to measure something to have time
and this spell is cheating and he
doesn't even know and people who look at
this don't even know what he's doing
he's he has location there and he calls
it time okay
uh so that slice is not time its
location
okay so um what does he do with this
well he's going to represent and here he
shows it really uh why he's mistaken
he's going to put clocks in each one of
those slices
okay and that's a serious problem
because you cannot have a clock in a
single slice
uh time requires an interval which is a
synonym of time in other words you need
at least two uh frames of the movie okay
you cannot have time in a single frame
single frame you have location that's
all you have there okay so again this is
a misconception what he's showing there
but you can see what his intent was it
was to
slice across space-time
and he calls each one of those slices
time okay so he's you know I'm getting
to that because someone asked something
here I think it's this fella
I know here we have the I'll get to that
in a second here's the Wikipedia
definition of time because of all these
people and again we don't have any
definition says the definite continued
progress of existence and events that
occur in an apparently irreversible
succession from the past through the
present into the future well past
present and future there are all three
of them the words at the bottom there
are defined as in terms of time so we
can't use those words to Define time
itself and then the question is of
existence does time exist well the
ability of an entity to interact with a
physical or mental reality
what's that got to do with time existing
I have no idea because we're not talking
about interaction of time with anything
okay so and again existence has these uh
synonyms reality real and being which
you can't use synonyms to Define
existence let alone to talk about the
existence of time so whatever's in the
dictionary or in the encyclopedias is
bunk it's nonsense you can't make any
sense of it a lot of it because it's
they're using def um synonyms and a lot
of it because the words themselves that
they use are undefined like existence
you cannot talk about the existence of
time if you don't know what existence
means that's one issue and then the
other one is time is uh defined as
existing existing is a static concept
you don't need to have motion to exist
time requires motion so the word
existence and the word time are
incompatible from a definitional point
of view okay you cannot you talk about
the existence of time if time is dynamic
and existence is static okay that's
that's my point
okay uh so what what do I do is uh put
them in the proper context with a
universal movie you can see time is not
up there it's down there at the bottom
right it's a dynamic concept what's the
difference between static and dynamic
Concepts static Concepts is only one
frame in the Universal movie all you
have is in one frame is location
distance you have object you have
existence all those are static Concepts
you can conceptualize all that in a
single frame of the universal movie if
you want to conceptualize any of the
ones at the bottom motion plasma field
whatever and time you need at least two
frames of the universal movie you cannot
conceptualize though any of those words
at the bottom
in a single frame okay all those words
embody motion okay
okay so one fella does say
s here and then we do need to answer him
because uh he raises an interesting
issue he says stopping the universe is a
dynamic concept
uh-huh so
here we have time at the bottom and he
says well but you're stopping the
universe that's dynamic
well we're not stopping the universe
okay so let's make sure we understand
that we're looking at a single frame of
motion okay remember that's a motion
picture that's what they would call
moving pictures and we're looking at a
single frame in that frame we only have
location it's like what uh Brian Green
tried to do a minute ago where he sliced
across space-time you know the motion of
the universe
he's got location not time he's got a
single frame
cross-section of time cross-section of
motion that's only location you don't
have time in a cross section of time
you need an interval you need at least
two frames in a movie to conceptualize
time so no we're not stopping the
universe we're looking at a single frame
and conceptually it's like slicing
across motion and all you end up with is
location okay it's not like we're
stopping the universe and saying oh we
stopped from this motion that was
happening no that's not what we're doing
we're
cutting across the movie and slicing a
single frame we're taking a snapshot
God's camera we're taking a snapshot of
the movie and looking at the snapshot in
that frame okay in that frame there's no
motion it's not like we're saying oh but
that came from motion that came before
it no no that's not what we're saying
we're saying that frame when you look at
any picture
in your house just any picture that you
want that snapshot that you took there's
no Motion in there hopefully unless you
drank 10 beers okay
in that picture there's no motion and
that's what we're saying we're looking
at only distance we're looking at
location was there motion before you
took the picture of course Irrelevant in
the picture there's no motion
so no uh we're not talking about
stopping the universe we're talking
about location okay and so do not a
single frame of the film so please do
not confuse those okay so what is time
okay so here we have a little definition
that you can take home and you know sink
your teeth into this the Earth travels
at 30 kilometers in one second around
the Sun
one second motion of the hand on the
clock right is equal to 30 kilometers
motion of the Earth around the Sun so
for every tick of one second on your
clock the Earth moved 30 kilometers
and if you multiply that times a big
amount I can't remember I'm going to
think it's like 48 000 seconds or
whatever uh if you if you look at that
and then you'll find or 48 million
seconds I think it is whatever the point
is when you look at that that gives you
the the value of a year okay in
mathematical terms so what what you're
doing from a qualitative point of view
every time you look at a second if you
look if you look at a second you're
saying what am I what is a second well a
second is a comparison of that tick mark
the motion of that tick mark from A to B
what we call one second on the clock and
in that same time the Earth went around
the Sun
30 kilometers
so you're comparing two motions the
motion of the Earth
versus the motion of the hand from A to
B for that one second tick mark okay and
so time is what a comparison of two
motions that's what all these people
always said but they never were able to
Define it saying Augustine thank you you
don't have to thank me but there it is
it's a comparison of two motions time
requires memory you must remember the
original starting point of whatever
you're measuring okay so uh uh it does
require memory okay and obviously you
have to also memorize them whatever
you're using to measure that like in
this case if you're measuring the motion
of the Earth around the Sun you have to
also record memorize the origin of the
hand on the clock before it moves to the
next tick mark
okay so you're comparing those two
motion time originated when
Consciousness evolved time requires
memory yes
um there was no time before life uh
originated on Earth We're Not the Only
animal on Earth that has a sense of time
I argue that
um animals such as maybe lions for
example uh you know they see the
wildebeest they go on their yearly tour
on their migrations and when they come
back you know around uh where the lions
are because they want water or whatever
or because of uh just tradition for
whatever the lions are waiting they know
it's it's time
it's that time of the year again uh when
the when the uh
deer come back or the Buffalo come back
or whoever you know uh the zebras they
know that it's coming and they expect it
so they have a clock uh more like a
calendar uh they have a notion of time
they also have a notion of time when
they believe that they can catch an
animal they do not start running they
did not start you know Galloping truck
after
an animal unless they already have a
sense of whether they can catch it
okay so even then sometimes they fail
but the point is that's how close it
gets okay they they really run after an
animal they want to kill
only when it's close enough that they
already have a notion of their own speed
and the speed of that animal
so they have a notion of time you can
say you know stop watch they say okay
he's a few three seconds away I'll run
now that's more or less the notion of
time they have so they have a a
rudimentary
notion of time and I'm sure other
animals have similar Notions we have a
very sophisticated notion of time but
uh time began with Consciousness without
Consciousness all we had was a uh uh
what is a pinball machine out there an
automatic pinball machine you know
asteroids went around moons went around
uh uh things collided uh supernovas
exploded Etc all that was happening
but there was no one no consciousness to
evaluate comparisons you needed
comparisons and you needed to memorize
the original point in order to make the
comparisons okay because now
the um the asteroid is at a new location
but unless you memorize its early
location
and compared it against something
whatever measuring device you have yeah
unless you made that comparison and you
remember the original location you do
not have time you will only have time
when you have a starting point and
ending point and a measuring device also
has a starting point and ending point
you're comparing two motions
okay okay uh we have our uh
science critic
and he thinks that mathematics you know
predictions
involve explanations
and that is absolutely not true but
before we get there fella had a comment
and he said the following says damn this
dude kind of weird I'm a long-haired man
as well because I find it cool but I
never even I never seen a man paint
their nails red before
uh you know black at most I hope he
doesn't chemically castrate himself uh
with a transgender scam in all honesty
for the well-being of his physical
health
yeah this uh fellas um I don't know he
was trying to draw attention or wants to
be with The Fad going out there with
some uh some in the new generation which
they paint their nails and shave their
legs and do stuff like that nature and
you know those are not considered very
masculine traits they're considered
feminine traits and one of the things
that pops in normal people's minds is uh
whether we are uh whether all this is
whether humans episting men are becoming
more feminine and women more masculine
you know there is this trend out there
and people are analyzing these things I
guess that's what this fellow was
referring to but anyways yeah if he was
trying to draw attention with his
painted nails uh he did catch my
attention
okay I'm from a different age sorry guys
uh this is new to me these fads okay but
let's get on with the subject matter and
this is what this fellow had to say
about
um
predictions and how they relate to
explanations okay let me put them on
here it goes
the questions and issues to be addressed
in this rebuttal include well as most
people out there this fellow has no idea
that there are no explanations at all or
even possible in mathematics
an equation can be used to predict
meaning to describe
a prediction is just a description and
never an explanation of the physical
mechanism
a car is traveling at 15 miles per hour
the mathematician can predict that it
will be 50 miles away from origin if it
travels on a rectal in your path
even if the prediction materializes all
that the mathematician has done is
describe what's going to happen
well actually there's something that you
missed they build if you know that a car
is going to be 50 miles away after an
hour then you know why it's going to be
50 miles away don't you because it's
traveling at 50 miles an hour now let's
say that you have two competing
hypotheses here one says that after an
hour the car is going to be 75 miles
away because it is traveling at 75 miles
an hour and the other says that after an
hour is going to be 50 miles away
because it is traveling at 50 miles an
hour if after an hour it is 50 miles
away then the explanation that it was
traveling at 50 miles an hour becomes a
whole lot more plausible
okay so um
looks like it's an open and shut case
he's saying uh he was able to explain
why the car is 50 miles away
because it was traveling 50 miles per
hour you know 50 miles away after one
hour because it was traveling at 50
miles per hour
sounds like he's right doesn't it well
what he doesn't understand is that all
he's done is reword the description
a mechanism is what is missing he's not
telling us the physical cause the
mechanism of how the car got over there
that's an explanation
so all he did was reword he rephrased
his description and saying the reason
why description
the car is 50 miles away from its
starting point after one hour is because
it was finally at 50 miles per hour
that's the notion of ordinary speech
that's the notion of explanation of
mathematics of the religion of
mathematics it has nothing to do with
explanations or with physics okay with
science okay so let's look at that okay
that's not an explanation okay here we
have it prediction is a description
always
never an explanation if you can explain
why something happened you're no longer
predicting now you're drawing on your
experience now you're talking about the
past okay explanation is always about
the Past prediction is always about the
future
okay so you cannot predict the past and
you cannot explain the future okay if
you can explain the future you're not
explaining the future you're explaining
what you already know what you already
have experience with what you've already
tested or whatever you you have already
experienced with the explanation that's
why you can explain
okay here you have uh what these words
mean so that we can put them in the
right uh context description just a
listing of attributes of an object
that's what description is and nothing
but for the purposes of physics a
description is typically affected with
adjectives okay you say the table is red
it's high it's heavy it's made out of
metal you know what you're doing is
describing
okay
we describe objects we like to use the
word narrative or narration for Dynamic
Concepts with behaviors okay and again
we're not talking about an explanation
we're just talking about the facts man
just the facts okay we're just saying
this is what happened okay it's usually
a chronological account of a phenomenon
it's you could call it description right
of an event okay so you can continue
using the word description if you want
but the point is we we would like we
would prefer to use description for
listing of attributes of an object and
narrative or narration for how an object
moved okay what happened okay narrative
mostly invokes adverbs in an equation
verbs obviously right an equation is
just a description okay so all equations
of math are just descriptions they're
narratives in that sense how something
happened
speed time weight displacement Force
energy Etc okay that's what you're doing
with a narrative and usually it's
chronologically what is an explanation
something totally different than
narrative or description it's
identifying the causes and mechanisms
underlying a phenomenon do we need
numbers no do we need to describe
anything no do we need to know the speed
or the weight or how much energy
something had no we don't need any of
that to explain the cause or explain a
mechanism okay so those words belong uh
you know uh
such as wait time Etc all those belong
to mathematics
okay so uh just make sure you understand
the difference between these words once
we have defined these words now we can
use them consistently to uh counteract
what this fellow said he he said that uh
the fact that it's traveling 50 miles
per hour explains now it doesn't explain
all you did was describe the same thing
in different words and use the word
explain in an irrational Manner and
again you have to define the word
explanation explain
and differentiate it from description so
that we know what you're talking about
when you talk about describe and we talk
about explain and again we're saying
that predictions are only descriptions
that's that's all it is when you
describe that there's going to be a
um a uh for example a
um eclipse tomorrow
all you did was describe you haven't
explained why yet you just said tomorrow
at five o'clock in the afternoon there's
going to be an eclipse
and all you and if it happens fine you
know your prediction came true all you
did was describe so far you haven't
explained why it was going to happen why
it was going to happen at five o'clock
now if you can explain why now you're
drawing on on the past you're doing on
experience that's the only reason you
can explain why and you no longer are
talking about a an ex
prediction you're not talking about the
future anymore
okay and uh
here we have
give me a second here uh yeah we have
good old Einstein and he said that time
has worked
and so people say well that's an
explanation
well is it an explanation what we have
here is warp time what he's done is
replace time with a fish net he reified
the word time he puts a fishnet he could
have put a fish there he put it could
have put a uh a tree a rock a house
instead he puts a fish in it okay so why
a fishnet in what way is efficient
related to the word time
so he puts his fishnet we don't know
what the black stuff that gives
um contrast to The Fishnet is he hasn't
identified that and his says that the
reason this is the physical
interpretation of Relativity today that
the reason the Earth doesn't fly out of
the earth out of the solar system is
because time is Warped
that's not an explanation that's a
description turned around like this
fellow did with the 50 kilometers
what we have here really is that time is
considered to
Bend as they say or warp what what
they're really saying is that time goes
slower or faster at different levels of
gravity in other words uh if you take a
clock out into space it travels the the
clock ticks at a different rate than it
does here on Earth the word warped has
nothing to do with that event with that
phenomena so they they put this word
warped
which is a word that belongs to physics
which belongs to
The Fishnet but has nothing at all to do
with time and so what they're using is
they're using words of physics to talk
about a word of mathematics which is
time and they say look the clocks run
slower or the clocks run faster
well how does that prevent the Earth
from flowing from flying out of the
solar system
and again the Warped canvas there the
warp uh fishnet
is a uh is it has no analogy whatsoever
with with time
so they don't have a physical
interpretation they don't have an
explanation and this fellow buys that as
an explanation he says well they
explained it because the reason the
Earth doesn't fly out of the solar
system is time has worked and the reason
that the car ended up 50 miles away from
its origin after one hour is because why
because the car was traveling at 50
miles per hour no that's not a y That's
not a cause that's not an explanation
the reason the car ended up 50 miles
away is because the wheels were turning
because the carburetor was working
because the gas from the tank was
flowing into the motor that's a cause
that's an explanation of a mechanism
that's what we're looking for so when
these people
use mathematics and they talk about why
meaning explanation they're rephrasing a
description in terms of physics they're
converting a description into an
explanation and that's why these two
words need to be absolutely defined and
Ambiguously okay
okay uh we only had uh I only have one
uh comment other than the ones that I've
already covered today in each one of the
uh groups there and Cisco he says
picture of a thought
and goes into details uh that's all I
can understand from his videos he wants
he asked me to look at two of his videos
and I looked at them and again uh you
know he's got a subject matter that
doesn't interest me at all uh you're
picking on the wrong guy fellow I'm
sorry
um uh I think he's just trying to make a
picture of a thought in other words the
way I look at it still look at it in the
same way I saw it last week and the week
before and that's he's trying to map out
the brain and you can go to any level
you want you can go to whatever detail
you want you can look at the brain as a
whole
with electrical signals coming out of
there if you put the electrodes you can
look at the individual uh cells that
form the brain and you can look at the
atoms that form the brain together with
a electricity and magnetism floating in
there even gravity if you want so you
can look at all it depends on what
amount of detail you want and I I think
what he's trying to get to is a picture
of the brain and identify that picture
at whatever level there that I just
discussed uh he related to some uh image
for example if you're thinking about a
cat right so the the
cells or the atoms in the cells or the
magnetism flowing around there or the
electricity floating in there or the
chemical reactions whichever one you
want we take a cross-section of that
take a snapshot in other words of the
brain at that point and we say look this
pattern
this relation between all these uh
things that influence your way of
thinking represents a cat so when we
look at that picture we say we know
that's a black cat and if it's got an
atom out of alignment or something else
or maybe the magnetism is a different
direction we say well that's a gray cat
or a white cat or whatever so we would
be able to identify a map of the brain
with some kind of image that's a
cross-section if you take you know a
movie or a film strip of the movie you
can say well what's this guy thinking
about well he's thinking about a cat
moving uh maybe up a wall okay so now
you don't only have a cat which is a
single frame now you have motion which
is what the cat is doing which is moving
up uh you know a wall or whatever a tree
uh I don't think we'll ever get to that
point okay and I think that's what he's
trying to get to eventually because I
keep understanding this issue in the
same way no matter what he says okay I
keep looking at it in that direction but
he says the arrangement well this this
is my criticism of his uh the
arrangement of Adams is that what he's
looking at
um we have uh an atomic system
configuration is that equal to a certain
thought I would say it is I mean if I
had the eyes of God you know the mind of
God I could look inside a brain look at
all the atoms in there and say this is
what this guy's thinking not because uh
well the reason I know this is that I've
already mapped that and know that this
represents a cat and this other pattern
represents a house and this one
represents a rock and then if you look
at a film strip you can say well this
guy's thinking about a girl moving you
know from A to B because that's what all
the this film strip all these uh
Arrangements of atoms moving through
time right so to speak uh that's what it
represents I think he's trying to map
the brain and somehow get thought out of
there and he does give an example of a
Japanese who allegedly did something
along those lines where they I guess put
the electrodes and say well to get an
idea of what this guy's thinking about
you know uh how much of that uh we can
really pinpoint we can get a ballpark
figure maybe you know the fact that they
do put the electrodes on people and get
an idea what the guy is thinking about
because the guy later on maybe tells him
or maybe they put the electrodes in in
the guy's head and they make him think
of love it could be sex uh maybe the
guy's got to watch a girl or some a
sexual scene so they know he's thinking
about sex and they ask him to think
about sex they put the electrodes and
they get a general pattern of the
electricity coming out of his brain and
the magnetism and they say okay this guy
every time he gets these stuff thoughts
we get this pattern and that represents
the sex that he's watching it's
something along those lines how much we
can really figure that out in any detail
I don't know is that part of physics
yeah you could say the physical part is
if there is a pattern that you can map
out
and somehow related to a thought yeah I
guess you could do that how much we're
going to achieve with that I doubt very
much
I'm not sure we're going to go very far
with that
um again thought is dynamic and um
you know he was talking about schizo
which is a behavior and that's different
than a cat which is an object again
you're talking about film strip versus a
cross-section of your brain you know
what you're thinking at a cross section
what the pattern looks like what does
that represent does that represent a cat
a house at a rock Etc and then he goes
into second uh video he goes on
intention and yeah he lost me completely
because I'm not interested in intention
at all it's a subject matter that does
not concern me all this uh what people
think opinions uh philosophy it doesn't
concern me at all I'm interested only in
physics so uh uh maybe you gotta go see
some other Guru for that okay we'll see
you next week with us uh we're gonna go
to a
uh tangential subject